مساء الخير اصدر بنك ستاندرد تشارترد بنك
البريطاني تقرير عجيب غريب في 8 يناير
اللي فات وقع فيه انه مصرع تبقى سابع اكبر
اقتصاد في العالم بحلول سنه الفين وثلاثين
ويترك تبقى اكبر اقتصاد في العالم
تعالوا نشوف مؤسسه للتقرير كل بيقول ايه
بيتوقع انها اكبر عشر اقتصادات في العالم
مرتبه على النحو التالي الصين في المركز
الاول ثم الهند ثم الولايات المتحده
بكادرها في المركز الثالث ثم اندونيسيا في
الرابعه تركيا في الخامس البرازيل في
الثالثه مصر السابع روسيا في المركز
الثامن ثم اليابان ثم المانيا اخيرا في
المركز العاشر الحقيقه للتقرير اثار حاله
من الجدل وطبعا حاله من الاحتفاء والبهجه
في مصر اللي تلقفته وسائل الاعلام
واعتبرته دليل وسائل الاعلام المؤيده
للحكومه واعتبرته نادي دليل على نجاح
سياسات الحكومه الاقتصاديه الرشيده الاغرب
انه بعض المسؤولين ابتدا يستدل بهذا
التقرير علشان يدلل على وجاهد السياسات
الحكوميه وفي حدود معلوماتي انه في تركيا
ايضا استقبل استقبالا طيبا واقع الامر انه
يعني ان التقرير برمته في تقديري المتواضع
لا يستحق النظر من الاساس التقرير يعني
بني اعتبارات وعلى مجموعه او بني
الخطيره بناء على مجموعه من الافتراضات
اللي هو يعتقد انها تفضل قائمه لمده 11
سنه دون اي تغيير كبير لا يجارى يعني ظهور
مثلا اه سفارات نتيجه وجود تكنولوجيا
جديده ولا يعني تطورات سلبيه نتيجه الحروب
او اضطرابات تفترض عنده مجموعه من الارقام
بني عليها معدل نمو السكان النمو نسبه
التضخم يعني عمل مجموعه كبيره من
الافتراضات وتخيل انه لو على هذا معادلات
يبقى الوضع التالي عندنا هذا الترتيب اهم
معيار اعتمد عليه اهم معيار النظر اعتمد
على التقرير ده
هو نسبه ارتفاع السكان اعتقد انه العشر
دول دول منهم سبعه الدول بيسموه من دول
اميركا او الدول ما ميه اللي هي زي الهند
وزي البرازيل وزي مصر وتركيا واندونيسيا
اعتقد انه الافتراض الاساسي انه طالما عدد
السكان ها يزيد مقارنه بيعرض سكان العالم
يبقى في النهايه عدد السكان ده يتحول الى
اي عامله وايضا يبقى تزود عاده تزود
الانتاج وبالتالي لما يزيد الانتاج يزيد
عدد ما تنتهي من خدمات وسرعه نهائيه لما
نيجي السلع والخدمات
القيم النقديه يطلع لنا الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي يبقى ترتيب هذه الدول هيك يتقدم
في ترتيب العالم او ترتيب دول العالم من
حيث الناتج المحلي الاجمالي احنا محتاجين
والتي المحلي الاجمالي
محتاجين نفهم هو وبناءا على ايلان في اكثر
من طريقه لكن في النهايه هو يعتبر ان مصر
الناتج المحلي بتاعها الان هو ومائتين
مليار دولار ب بمعيار اسمه المعادله القوى
الشرعيه في سنه الفين وثلاثين
بنسبه خمسه مائه وثلاثه وثمانين في البيئه
ثمانيه واثنين من عشره اخرين وطبعا بقيه
الدول بغض ترتيبها يعني الصين هادي حوالي
اربعه وستين
الهند 46 امريكا تفضل واحد وثلاثين مليار
تركيا تسعه واحد من عشره مليون
والمانيه تحل مؤخرا سته وتسعه من عشره
مليون دولار نحن نفهم القصه معيار الاساسي
اللي بينا عليه التقرير حساباته مبني على
اساس الزياده السكانيه
على سبيل المثال عشان نفهم التقرير
والتقارير يعني
جرت انهى بتصدر عن في دوله غربيه التقرير
مبني على اساس انه فكره ان الزياده
السكانيه
لحضراتكم ها تنعكس بالضروره على التج
المحلي الاجمالي هذا الافتراض بالاساس
افتراض غير دقيقه
ولو كان هذا الافتراض دقيق كان به اقصد
مثال او ابسط مثال على ان هذا الافتراض
غير دقيق هو انه اسرائيل حوالي سته مليون
مواطن سعداء والجيل
المحل الاميه بتاع في 2017 قلت ميه وخمسين
مليار دولار في مقابل ان تك المحلي
الاجمالي لمصر اللي هي عمليه مليون اقل من
مائتين وخمسين مليار تحديدا بان سبعه
وثلاثين مليار يعني هذا ليس ما يراه ثم
بالاساس الصين اللي هي مليار و 300 مليون
والولايات المتحده الفلسطينيه خمسه وعشرين
مليون مازالت هي اكبر من الصين بعده
تريليونات يعني اه يعني مثلا الصين امريكا
في 2017 الكلام على اربعه وعشرين بليون في
مقابل حوالي 14 و 15 تريليون للصين كل
السفارات اللي عملتها
والهند البلد الثاني استعان بها الاقتصاد
الامريكي مقارنه او اعتمادها على حجم
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي عشر اضعاف
الاقتصاد الهندي اللي هي المليار سمحت
بدايه
الافتراض الاساسي الام عليه التقرير الامر
الثاني طريقه الحساب
فرقه الحساب الاساسيه هو اعتمد على قياس
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي نادي المحلي
وخاصه بطريقتين الطريقه الاولى هي يسموها
النوع من الجديد طبعا اللي من حضرتكم مش
عارف يعني اه الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
استاذ نرجع الى حلقه
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي على قناتنا وفيها
شرح
المحلي الاجمالي لكن اذكركم مره ثانيه
ببساطه المحلي الاجمالي معناه القيم
النقديه او القيمه النقديه لاكمال ما
تنتبه اي دوله او دوله ما من سلع اه
نهائيه من سلع وخدمات نهائيه خلال فتره
معينه ولتكن عام وبالتالي بتيجي دوله
الدوله دي ولتكن مثلا مصر او السودان او
العراق بتشوف اجمالي ما انتجته من السلع
والخدمات
ال حزبه دي بت حسمها بالعمله المحليه
وبعدين لانه العمله المحليه بينما تعيش
الكثير بالنسبه للاطراف الخارجين في كل
دوله تحول الكلام من عملتها او تحاول
الحزب بدي من عملتها الى
عملهم يعرفوها اللي هي الدولار كعمله
الاحتياطي العالمي فبتكون النتيجه انه لما
بيجي بيحاول بيحول بناء على انه معيار على
سعر الصرف يعني مثلا في مصر مدنيه الدولار
ب 18 جنيه فهو بيجي يحسب الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي المصري وليكن ثلاثه ونصف ليون
اربعه مليون جنيه مصري ويحولهم يقسم على
الثمنطاشر فيكون النتيجه ان عنده حوالي
مائتين وخمسين مليار دولار مصري كل دوله
بتعمل نفسه قصدي بنلاقي عندنا لما يشوف
ترتيب دول العالم وفقا
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي اللي بيعبر على
قدره الاقتصاد
يعني
بتلاقي ترتيب الدول موجود عاده او طول
الوقت يعني الولايات المتحده لان مدار على
مدار سبعين سنه هي الاقتصاد الاكبر في
العالم والاول عشرين مليون دولار
والتلفزيون الف مليار من فضلك دول العالم
تباعا بعدها الصين ثم اه عندك المانيا
واليابان وبريطانيا وفرنسا وصولا الى
الدول الصغيره في جنوب السودان اللي
الناتج المحلي الايمان بتاعها اقل من
الثلاثه مليار دولار لطريقه في طريقه
ثانيه
الاقتصاديين لاحظوا ان الطريقه
بحجم الدول بالارقام الاسميه لكن بالطريقه
دي الطريقه مش بالضروره بتعكس مستوى معيشه
البشر بمعنى انه الدولار في امريكا بيشتري
اداء الجنيه المصري يشتري فمصر بغض النظر
لما انا ا حولهم بسعر الصرف
فبيقول مثلا انه الجنيه الدولار في امريكا
بيشتري لتر بنزين
لكن الدولار في مصر
لكن
اللتر البنزين في مصر بحوالي 600 معنى كده
انه الدولار يساوي في طريقه ثانيه لحسابه
بسعر صرف ما يساوي 18 انما بمعيار القوه
الشرعيه هو بيت جنيه طيب المساله الحياه
من البنزين بس هو بيعملوا
مجموعه من السلع سله من السلام حوالي مائه
سنه مثلا ياخذ مائه في المائه سلعه في
الولايات المتحده ويشوفك بتهم كان وياخذ
بنفس المائه دول في مصر ويشوف كانت هم كان
ولا يكن المائه سلع دول تساوي الف دولار
في امريكا تقدر تشتري الف دولار نفس هذه
الوحدات تقدر تشريعها في مصر بسته
سعر الدولار بمعيار القوه الشرائيه بمعيار
العمله المحليه في بلدنا يبقى الدولار
يساوي سته من
يسموا
في طريقه اخر لحساب الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي اجازه مصر الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي بتاعها القيمه الاسميه يعني
بحساب سعر صرف الجنيه مقابل الدولار حوالي
مائتين واربعين مليار دولار اقل من مائتين
وخمسين انا بعرف يعني في 2017 تحرير
مائتين وسبعه وثلاثين لكن بحساب بالقوه
الشرائيه يعني قدره الجينيه الشرقيه في
مصر مقابل الدولار بيشتري في امريكا بلاقي
من الرقم يزيد كثير جدا
للاسباب اللي انا شرحت على حضرتك هل مصر
استثناء هل تركيا استثناء
الحقيقه انه الجهات اللي بتحصل الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي مقاوما بالقدره الشرعيه
وهي البنك الدولي وصندوق النقد وغيره من
الجهات وتحديدا للبنك الدولي اللي يحس بها
كل سنه اسم دول العالم المائه اثنين
وتسعين دوله الى ثلاث فئات او لفئه سهله
جدا لان مفاجئ الدوله واحده الولايات
المتحده الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
هو واحد سواء حسبته القيمه الاسميه او حسب
معادل القوى الشرعيه لان العمله بتاعتها
هي عمله القياس فهي بكل الاحوال رقم واحد
ولذلك هي في سنه الفين وثلاثين وفقا
للتقرير المذكور هيبقى الجديده بيت واحد
وثلاثين مليون دولار
باي
بالطريقتين باقي دول العالم المائه واحد
وتسعين دوله مقسمين كالتالي منهم مائه
وثمانيه وسبعين دوله مائه وثمانيه وسبعين
دولي هي الدول الفقيره والناميه الدولي
يقول لها دائما يكون الحساب معامله القوه
الشرعيه اعلى من الحساب بالقوى الاسميه
وفضل 13 دوله اللي هي الدول المتقدمه
الاخرى في بريطانيا زي المانيا زي اليابان
يكون في الحساب بالقيمه الاسميه
اعلى من الحساب بالقوى الشرعيه تبدا معناه
اولا يكون فيه فرق لما حسب الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي بمعادله قوه شرعيه
يختلف عن لما بحسم والقيمه الاسميه
المساله الوساطه انه الحياه السلع
والخدمات بتقدم بشكل ارخص في الدول
الفقيره والناميه ومنهم مصر
ومنهم طبعا كل الدول اللي انتو تصنع انها
كل دول المنطقه عندنا مثلا والسبب يرجع
ببساطه لعده ازمات او في مجموعه اسباب
بسيطه واضحه اولها هو
العماله الرخيصه العامل المصري يتقاضى
اجرا اقل بكثير جدا جدا جدا من عمل
الولايات المتحده وكذلك في الصين وكذلك
فان دخول الدولي بتقاضي امور اقل من
الدوله المتقدمه وهما بيعتقدوا امور اقل
لانهم اعمالها اقل مهاره في الغالب
وبالتالي بيتقال امور اقل وبالتالي السلع
بتكون اقل العامل العمل الثاني انا انا
عندي نوعيه الضرائب الدول المتقدمه
الضريبه الجميع بيدفعها وبدرجه عاليه جدا
من الدقه احنا عندنا هنا في الغالب
الضرائب اما ما بندفعها لان احنا عندنا
كثير من اقتصاداتنا اقتصادات الغير
الرسميه يعني خارج المنظومه بالاساس السلع
بتيجي بدون اي ضرائب النتيجه انه السلع
الرخيصه لا ممكن يفيد المواطن في موقف ما
لكن الصوره الكليه من الدوله ما بتحصل شعر
ضرائب بتكون اجازه على تقديم خدمات
للمواطنين
عندي اسباب
كثير يعني عندي اسباب كثيره لا مو انا
اللي
مرتفعه من ضمن الاسباب دي انا انا ب سعر
الصرف
اه اه اه دولار يساوي 18
اهمها العرض والطلب انا ب صدر بانديه
وتستورد بدايه بلاقي مصر تستورد اكثر من
ثلاثه اضعاف اللي بتصدر به وبالتالي بيكون
الطلب على الجني اقل بكثير جدا من طلبها
على الدولار النتيجه ان الحزب تتحسب
المعيار الثاني اللي هو معادله القوه
الشرائيه في السلع
وفيه خدمات تحديدا غير قابله للتداول
انت بتشارك بكم وانت بتروح دكتور الاسنان
بكم وان تستعين بمدرسه مع اولادك بكامل
حاجات دين مش قابله للتصدير ولا للاستيراد
كل السلع كل نوع من الخدمات هي خدمات
منخفضه وخاصه بالبلد على عكس مثلا لما
بتشكرك ان يكون سهلا ايفون
لانه حاجه بيتم تبادل
البطن لاين او الملخص
فكره ان في دوله يكون ان جيبي بيتها
مقاومه
او
معادل القوه الشرائيه
اعلى بكثير من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لها
مقومات
بالقيمه الاسميه المعروفه هذا لا يعني غير
ان الاسعار المنخفضه والاسعار المنخفضه
ليس لاي شيء مش توفرت السلام ولكن الاسباب
اللي انا ارسلكم عليها التشوهات اللي
موجوده في الاقتصاد الناتج عن انخفاض ال
اه يعني اسماء امور العماله الناتجه عن
وجود اقتصاد الرسمي بيتعرض من دفع الضريبه
انها تجي عن وجود اشكال مختلفه كبيره من
الدعم في البطوله وفي الكهربا وفي البنزين
وبالتالي اسعار السلع ما بتكون يعني دقيقه
كل ده يعني ان الاقتصاديه فيها اختلالات
مش فيها او تقدم
المعيارين انا اعتبر عليهم بالتقرير
يعني الترتيب الصين في الاول والمانيا في
الاخر وبينهم امريكا وبينهم تركيا ومصر
اعتبارات غير دقيقه ما تستحق كثيرا
الالتفات اليها في التقرير الوهمي ونرجع
على ارض الواقع ونشوف التقارير ال الوضع
الحالي مصر وفقا للتقرير التنافسيه اهداف
المبتدا اللي منتدى دافوس بيقول انه احنا
الثمانيه وتسعين على من
148 دوله يعني الترتيب قدرت قدره الاقتصاد
المصري على المنافسه هي في المركز
الثمانيه وتسعين من مائه واربعين دوله
تقرير سهوله الاعمال اللي بيصدر عن البنك
الدولي بيقول انه ترتيب مصريه وعشرين
مائه وتسعين دوله والغريب انه مجلس
الوزراء والحكومه اصدرت بيانا ما يعني انا
فخوره بهذا الانجاز بدات رتبنا الحاله
اتمنى ان يكون كلام ستاندر سليم ونبقى من
اكبر اقتصادات في العالم وانه تركيا وبقي
دول المبدا يبقى في اوضاع جيده جدا لكننا
لا يتاتى بالافتراضات الخزي عمليه اللي
عملها التقرير ولكن ب طفره ضخمه جدا في
التعليم وفي الانتاج وفي المشروعات
التنمويه الزراعيه والصناعيه وت فرات في
على مستوى التشريعات وعلى مستوى الحريات
وعلى مستوى الاعلام قبائل غير متحقق في
الوقت الحالي
افضل كل ما سمعت تعليقا على هذا التقرير
الغريب من خبير الاستثمار المصري المعروف
الاستاذ هادي توفيق اللي مساله تعرف حدثت
ستاندر اللي انا يعني اللي التعليق اللي
انا مش عارف مين اللي كتب التقرير ولكن في
الغالب هو شخص نوع حشيش عاليه جدا اشكركم
والى لقاء اخر باذن الله
[موسيقى]